we feel you captain jack that was our
exact reaction when we found out there
are actually multiple versions of
almost every disney movie while a lot of
the time movies are able to just
dub over their actors voices in a
different language and call it a day
things sometimes get lost in translation
and other times cultures are just so
different that jokes and animations can
just be downright confusing
we dug up some of the most shocking
changes that have been made to your
favorite disney films
let's get into it i can't find it it
doesn't seem to be on
any of these stations to fans across
north america moana
is the name of one of disney's newest
princesses the unconventional water
goddess that had everyone searching for
where the line meets the sea for months
i am one hero of men what however to
europe
the name moana failed to make the cut in
multiple countries
the polynesian princess actually shares
a name with an
adult film star yep you heard us
so understandably disney's italian team
was a bit worried that people would
associate the princess with the adult
star's work
and prevent their kids from watching the
film so moana was changed to vayana in
france
and oceana in italy her name was also
changed for her appearance in the
wreck-it ralph film as well
we may never watch moana the same way
again
how could anyone ever forget the film
that truly introduced us to lindsay
lohan
while she may be a touch more
problematic in today's industry her
childhood years were spent giving us
iconic movies like disney's the parent
trap
so remember you're going to find out how
mum and dad met and you're going to find
out why they broke up
and while in america that's the film
she's known for we would bet all our
money that someone in germany would have
no clue what the parent trap is
instead they renamed the film to a twin
rarely comes alone
we'll admit that the alternate title
really does kind of sum up the movie in
an odd
way but is it just us or does that title
sound eerily like a horror film
finding dory wasn't exactly the sequel
to finding nemo we were all expecting
but
nonetheless it was everything pixar and
disney creators knew that after a
13-year gap they needed to make the film
extra special my family i remember my
family
they're out there somewhere i have to
find them to do that they made the movie
unique to different countries across the
world
when dory sets out on her adventure to
find her parents and ends up in the
marine life institute
she's guided by a disembodied voice from
the marine life institute's pa system
welcome to the open ocean
this character was actually voiced by a
different actor depending on the country
in english-speaking countries audiences
would have heard sigourney weaver
in france news anchor claire giselle and
in mexico
astronaut rodolfo neri vela cool
if you're a hardcore marvel and disney
fan you no doubt know the iron man 3
films by heart
but what if we told you that there's a
version of the film that is wildly
different
experience things and then they're over
and you still can't explain them
however this unique version was only
released in china
in the country the local chinese studio
dmg entertainment teamed up with marvel
studios to ensure that the film would be
culturally
appropriate for their audience the run
time of the movie included a more
in-depth focus on asian actors like dr
wu
and his nurse they even held a pretty
obvious advertisement for the chinese
milk brand guli duo
don't worry you didn't miss out on much
the scenes really had
no impact on the film's story arc
speaking of marvel
the avengers has been sweeping hollywood
and the entire blockbuster scene for at
least a decade now
however you might be shocked to know
that the films aren't called the
avengers in every country
who are you we're the avengers man
the uk actually decided to use their
phrase avengers assemble as their
official title instead
and their reason for doing it actually
makes a lot of sense
there was a british tv show called the
avengers back in the 1960s
it followed a secret agent duo james
bond
is that you the uk distributors decided
it was best to change the name of the
franchise so people wouldn't confuse the
two stories we're not gonna lie
avengers assemble sounds pretty iconic
which name do you prefer
this next disney film didn't have
anything in the actual
run time altered for an international
release but the official poster got a
remake in another country that makes
absolutely
no sense the hungarian artist tibor
helleni was tasked with making the
poster for a star wars film in hungary
he filled the poster with images of
creatures and robots that never appeared
in the film
when questioned about it he said he was
allowed to watch the movie before
drawing the poster but decided to add in
characters for his own amusement
inside out took some pretty complicated
topics and made it fun and entertaining
for not just kids but adults too
like its concepts they kept everything
simple
including the title however inside out's
title across the globe
got makeovers that were anything but
simple in fact
a lot of them make absolutely no sense
it's probably not important
chyna went for the great team inside the
head very straightforward of them
russia went with the very puzzling title
jigsaw
and vietnam decided to keep with those
puzzle vibes and went with the puzzle
emotions
but thailand takes a cake when it comes
to complication levels
they named it fantastical emotional
turmoil
safe to say if you're ever in need of a
good laugh you should definitely come
back to these
zootopia americans know it as a family
movie that follows a futuristic city
filled with all of our favorite talking
animals and critters
but not every country was fond of the
name
okay hold on keep watching who's that
beside her in the uk the film is
actually known as zootropolis
no one has ever really been given a
reason as to why the title was changed a
rep for disney was basically like
zootropolis sounds better and works
better for a uk audience
soccer hockey hockey soccer tomato
am i right well for people that aren't a
fan of sports
maybe but disney takes these things
super seriously
in the pixar film inside out we get a
glimpse into riley's dad's daydreams
if you're in america like us you
probably would have experienced his
daydream being about hockey
lake freeze is over and that's when we
play hockey i'm on a great team
we're called the prairie dogs however if
you're overseas
you might be a tad confused right now in
the european and
other international releases riley's
father was actually daydreaming about
soccer
this is because outside of north america
hockey isn't really a huge deal
shh don't tell dad soccer was just way
more culturally appropriate for the rest
of the world
speaking of inside out that wasn't all
they changed to appease international
audiences
in the scene where riley's baby sister
is resisting eating her veggies
hmm this looks new make it safe what is
it
who would have thought that refusing
broccoli could actually be offensive
spoiler alert it is in asian countries
broccoli is almost considered a delicacy
when it comes to veggies
so for disney's international releases
in asian countries the broccoli was
swapped for green beans
i mean equally as gross right pirates of
the caribbean
at world's end was one of 2007's biggest
films and that wasn't just in america
who doesn't want to see jack sparrow
prancing around his ship drinking rum
but what you probably don't know is that
disney dealt with a heck of a lot of
censorship problems when it came to the
film's release in china
you might remember notorious pirate
captain captain sao fang
his role was actually pretty important
to literally the entire plot
unfortunately his 20 minutes of screen
time were cut in half
sadly this is because people believed
that having a chinese villain would shed
a negative light on chinese people in
general
some people might find this next um
modification
kind of hilarious america might be one
of the world's global superpowers but
disney certainly knocked them down off
their high horse when they release toy
story 2 around the world when our pal
woody goes missing
and the other toys band together in
order to come up with a rescue plan
buzz puts on his brave face and gives a
life-changing speech to his friends
we have a friend in need in the american
movie the background behind him is the
american flag
if you're not in america you most likely
saw a montage of flags from across the
globe
who else wasn't expecting monsters
university when pixar announced a
monster inc
sequel we all thought we'd be getting
more of boo her door
and what exactly she's up to in the
2000s but instead
we got mike and sully in university
don't get us wrong it was epic but
what's even more epic is
how they changed the film to fit the fan
experience outside of america
when sully and mike and their newfound
friends are first introduced to the
scare games
the university has a banner up for
decoration that literally says
scare games we're not going to lose
because we have everything we need to
win
right here you probably figured out by
now that non-english speaking audiences
wouldn't be able to read the banner
outside of english-speaking countries
the banner was full of university
symbols instead of words so that would
work universally
mighty ducks a true disney classic and a
movie that will forever go down in
history
but in australia it might be going down
in history with quite a different name
now we're the ducks yeah and the ducks
are undefeated the 1992 movie was
released as champions in australia for
absolutely no reason
but that wasn't the end of the name
changing for australia
if you're owned the vhs we bet it says
the mighty ducks are the champions
doesn't matter if your favorite
character was mr incredible elastigirl
violet or
dash no villain had as much style in the
incredibles as
bomb voyage
i mean a mind villain epic but while we
all might laugh at his name being a play
of words on the french phrase bon voyage
the joke just doesn't hit the same in
french that's why in the french release
of the film the character was named
volamor
instead it translates into strange love
what do you think
unique or just plain odd the name of the
film was also altered in the french
version to lay zone in districts
which in english means the
indestructibles
what was the most shocking reveal for
you have you spotted any other changes
in international versions of your fave
movies
let us know what you think of all this
in the comment section below
don't forget to give this video a thumbs
up and hit that subscribe button for
more content just like this
over and out
you